est ce que tu te souviens seulement
encore de ce que l'on ressent quand on
vit loin tous béziers monde a changé
[Musique]
une nouvelle arme puissante que ce que
tu peux imaginer
ils tueraient des milliers de gens pas
de combat rien que la mort
arrêt laiterie 21 possède des armes qui
peuvent détruire les cités entières
dubaï à ce drame
nous avons maintenant une arme qui nous
rend inverse et aucune religion ne les
arrêtera la brutalité une solution plus
élégante je suis votre reine
[Applaudissements]
les soeurs nous a pourchassé pendant 17
années elle ne va pas s'arrêter
maintenant
on aurait plutôt que de laisser point
que ce soit arrivé un toit ou à nos
enfants
n'est jamais dû me battre pour ma
couronne
bientôt elle sera forgé sur la braise
les flammes de la guerre
ça
et elle fera de moi une reine ressuscité
[Musique]
je pense que tu sais ce que tu as fait
frappe encore
peut-être celui pour lequel vous avez
été mis sous boucle
[Musique]